meanwhile Moscow has dismissed an army
Commander after he criticized the
military leadership of failing troops in
Ukraine Major General Ivan Popov
commanded the 58th combined arms Army in
Ukraine's Zappa Ridge Eurasian for more
on this story let's bring in Julia
Schafer valova who's in Moscow Yulia
what more can you tell us about why
Popov was fired
well it's quite unprecedented really
that they dispute about problems in the
Russian army is gaining more and more
popularity here we understand that Major
General Ivan papov a high-ranking
military commander released an audio
appeal to the military claiming that he
had been dismissed from his pose for
criticizing the ministry of defense and
Reporting problems in the Army he was
the commander of the 58th combined armed
army as you said involved in the heavy
fighting in the southern zaparosia front
he was considered one of the most senior
generals participating in the Russian
Ukrainian conflict according to papov he
very harshly outlined all the
problematic issues in the Russian army
he said he told the leadership about the
absence of counter-battery combat Mass
deaths and injuries of soldiers from the
Ukrainian artillery he focused quote on
the most important tragedy of Modern
Warfare allegedly he proposed to rotate
the Russian units on the front line some
telegram channels also write that the
head of the general staff Valerie
garasim have accused Popov of alarmism
and blackmailing the top a leadership so
according to Papa now he's waiting for
his future fate and there are reports
that Lieutenant General Dennis liamin
has taken over the leadership of the
58th Army it's interesting also that
popov's address was distributed by state
Duma Deputy Andrei gurelov who also was
a commander of the 58th Army in the past
Julia what's going on inside the Russian
military why has there been so much
instability
well it's a good question really but
everyone has to come up to their own
conclusion we understand just earlier we
reported about reports from the chairman
of the Low House of Parliament and Drake
capsapol of about General Surah vikin
that General Surah vikin who is who was
actually involved allegedly was involved
in the failed military Rebellion late
led by evgeny preggers that General
survivica now having some rest and is
not available telegram channels also
wrote that he could be in the north
Caucasus
commander of the airspace forces and
Deputy head of the general staff of the
Russian army has not appeared in public
for two weeks since the Wagner group
armed rebellion and right now we have no
distant information about his
whereabouts so obviously all I can say
now that all those generals continue
being um well continued support the
military operation in Ukraine but none
of them at the moment says anything
about the uh the end of the military
operation all right thanks so much
Julius in Moscow for us